America Jimmy this kissing all about me
Sammy me lucky fellow
all right day four de cuatro I'm kidding
and I know my Spanish is better than
that
you
all right we've traveled far and wide
now just remember at but we're going to
eat breakfast
Oh
Oh
I ordered cheese Akitas uncoil how's
your Spanish is my Spanish better than
yours now your day so far I've been
really slow in both languages to them
just go Spanglish then so I'm just like
and that's why yesterday I kept talking
and talking ovie I like my Spanish
coming up I can be
we're on our way to different telephone
Gemini's ma'am yeah like did you fill me
mapping yeah I knew it oh how pretty
later okay you conveniently change the
subject no fun but it's a cute little
web low floors are so creaky that's how
you know it's official
how come this side of Mexico doesn't get
shown you know why so I you know what's
interesting my uncle was saying that
like media especially in America America
wants to scare Americans from coming to
Mexico so then Americans won't spend
their money in Mexico which makes a lot
of sense because the schools here are
cheaper and they're just good there's so
much beauty to see in Mexico but the
American media they always just focus on
the negativity that's happening into the
negative stuff that's happening like all
the crazy pencil stuff happens in like
the boonies like in North Mexico where
no one really goes to visit anyways
that's like American media's with a
credit
Americans like oh don't go it's ugly and
scary with no mexico's beautiful
gorgeous yeah I'm experienced the first
half
shame on you CNN in this town there's
like two churches there's an old church
and a new church the old church was
turned into a museum and how is it that
they're able to recreate a brand-new
church that looks as extravagant as it
would have come back in the day
why can't America create churches like
that our churches look like corporate
buildings yeah American yeah hey bring
anyone else say my selfie what I don't
take turns
yeah okay thank you bye bye
there's like signs I could have faked
for the benches for the frat like all
that even though these signs are near
like they still stick with the whole
team of the entire town or texwood and
like artisanal type so it makes you tell
me
prettier it makes you feel you're stuck
in this little bubble
you don't like bugs I could leave them
alone they want to do anything
harmless he's been having pain in his
arms instead of other forms of mommy's
be really that's an actual olden time
like remedy yeah my dad is crazy
in America we spent so much time
avoiding peace here I feel like I should
put it on here we go let's do it well
you could see it look on the side can
you see the finger yeah lady was like
yeah there's some people that really
always ask me I wanna get your natural
Mexican that's another one of
everything's awesome I guess again again
it's another local another is oh yeah
yeah tell me that it was it yeah there's
like the juice when the bee you say that
again
really really hurt like it seemed cuz I
didn't didn't sing as much Isaac or that
start it's a real man right there real
man
that's a mommy
oh Jesus
and this is absolutely gorgeous there's
like these huge rocks here open plains
open fields mountains all around us I
know I shouldn't be vlogging towards the
camera trying to climb these rocks right
now but uh Isaac's been bored out of his
mind last couple days oh here you go -
but yeah Isaac's been bored the last
couple of days with all the history
lessons and looking at historical
landmarks I think AG sik's been finally
fully activated here in nature well what
hmm
poke it whoa I was about to say be a boy
and poke more don't you want to poke it
you're poking you poke your [ __ ] eyes
like come on
but if I can't farmed I'm gonna be mad
it's just John Stoller alone or helping
I think become a boy hey Pinocchio
you're gonna be a real boy you're gonna
be over here you're gonna be a real boy
one day oh yeah baby guy you're not
gonna die is this about to be a
worldstar nice this is about the Google
world
hi oh really we'll start there I mean
fair fail I'm in state bail there was
like a movie
Isaac you like making a lot of noise
then you know in nature it's really good
not to make a whole lot of noise like
there was an animal that could eat you
and if it was close by and could hear
you you making noise is basically saying
hey come eat any lion or tiger or bear
really hits face I don't think I've ever
been this close to a cow it's close to a
cow without like fencing or anything
let's see a little closer
the Americans out of me says gold up
there okay I don't like no stop it leave
them in their nature will disturb them
like conflicting I mean like an internal
battle right now I want to touch
especially the baby of the believing
cats
you
you made it all right egg we gotta put
the camera take the camera all right
this is the over now guys all right we
made it safe out of the rain
camera safe we're semi dry but as usual
rain stops raining as soon as he in the
car but it's okay we're heading out to
better things now
it is time for my favorite time of the
day meal time you like Taco Bell tacos
or you like these kind of tacos better
cackles what
oh my gosh why I don't I was going to
say like you like the fast food tastes
like
you gotta be sensitizer so that's
American spin a day at an Asian fish
Mart and then you'll be good so we're
getting on the double-decker bus and
it's like a Lucha Libre tour
excited is
have you ever seen Mexican wrestling
they like to fall into the crowd and ask
for a little kid to come up and help me
we're gonna do I'll make sure I raise my
hand at sex again so you can go up there
and they'll throw you around
calling my bluff I think where are we
truck Isaac says we're on a truck no
actually I mean it's a double-decker bus
this is a way to experience Mexico right
here oh man what's happened
no you're too small huh you're just
laughing all the grown up throw light
all the girls Linc
I
coming on
it wasn't leaving
your best to tell or lucha libre moves
whoa oh here you need a partner a
wrestling partner builder and a dick you
learn - whoa you know you see some good
moves
oh whoa not the camera guy your mom he's
getting interactive with the crowd
what's your name
yeah yeah I have a name a blue panther
it's funny because every time they see a
couple in the street they tell them kids
then they actually kissed